تلاشت الصور الباهتة للسياسيين من
الانتخابات الأخيرة في لبنان قبل
ثلاث سنوات على جدران تاباني
أحد أفقر أحياء
طرابلس ثاني أكبر مدن لبنان
، وأعمالها الأكثر فقراً في
سوق السلع المستعملة هي
فقر بطيء هنا وهو
دائم الأغنى في لبنان.  هنا
في طرابلس يقول أحمد مصوال البالغ من العمر 62 عامًا
، إن الكلاب لا تهتم
بأي شخص يعيش أحمد مع 11 فردًا من
عائلته الممتدة في
غرفتين ضيقتين تركت سنوات من الأمطار الشتوية
بقعًا حيث تتسرب المياه في
غرفة الجلوس
التي تتضاعف  كغرفة نوم في الليل ،
صورة على الحائط تتحدث عن
أيام أفضل ، لقد مضى وقت طويل على أن أحمد
مريض لسنوات
لا يستطيع تحمل تكاليف الأدوية الأساسية أو
أي شيء
آخر لا أحتاج إلى اللحوم ، يقول إنني أشم رائحتها
من السوق ، إنها سنتان
ثلاث سنوات لا نعرف ما هو اللحم
في منزلي
الناشطة ليندا أحضرت الطعام المتبقي
من المطاعم إلى منزل
أحمد لمشاركته مع الفقراء في تاباني ،
لقد فقدت هي أيضًا  في السياسيين اللبنانيين ،
يجب أن نبكي وننزف ، وتبقى جميعًا
قادة ، تسأل
أنه ليس من المنطقي أننا سئمنا
[موسيقى] كانت
طرابلس مسرحًا لاحتجاجات عنيفة
ضد النخبة السياسية
في العامين الماضيين  فقدت العملة المحلية
أكثر من 80 في المائة من
قيمتها مقابل
التضخم السنوي للدولار العام الماضي ، وكان
معدل البطالة أكثر من 80 في المائة ،
وتتأرجح لبنان على شفا الانهيار
وكل ذلك بينما
يتنازع السياسيون على الغنائم المتقلصة
غير القادرين على تشكيل حكومة منذ ذلك الحين.
آخر واحد استقال منذ ما يقرب من ثمانية
أشهر بعد انفجار ميناء بيروت
وهم يهربون من الكارثة
يقول نضال صاحب متجر
إنهم يهربون من الانهيار
وهم يهربون من
السرقة لا توجد حكومة ونحن
نتجه نحو  فتحات الرصاص في الهاوية
القديمة على جدران هذه
المدينة تذكير بما
يمكن أن تجلبه تلك الهاوية لبين ويدمان CNN طرابلس
شمال لبنان.